[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va tester
en produits que j'ai pas l'habitude d'y
rester on va faire un boxing d'un
produit 100% gaming 100% gamer
alors quand on m'a proposé je me suis
dis bah pourquoi pas puisque au final vu
que je suis pas gamer vous que j'y
connais globalement pas grand-chose suis
même plutôt très mauvais très largué là
dedans je suis ça peut être cool de
découvrir les produits gamer donc on va
tout de suite s'attaquer à cette boîte
signé reaser et on y va maintenant
[Musique]
et
si je vous dis je vous réponds d'aller
voir je suis hyper hyper novice là
dedans et c'est justement pour ça que ça
m'intéresse si je vous dis
razer razer naga trinity je suppose que
ça vous parle du mois si vous êtes un
gamer je suppose que ça vous parle
produit spécial pour les gamers pour les
champions de world of warcraft et de
plein d'autres jeux dans le genre jeu
que je connais forcément je pas non plus
un gros dit non mais c'est vrai que j'ai
pas gamer quand on m'a proposé aurélien
à ce que ça t'intéresse de tester ses
produits
je me suis dit ouais cool ok bon coup on
y va pourquoi pour vraiment pouvoir
mieux comprendre l'univers du gaming
mieux comprendre les produits
alors je sais si vous êtes un gamer vous
avez vous dire qu'est ce que tu vas
comprendre avec uniquement un peu de
matos dans les mains alors c'est sûr pas
grand chose mais vaut mieux ça que rien
du tout ça me permet un petit peu de
voir un petit peu le matériel le sentir
essayer de voir un peu comment c'est
fait et voir en plus si moi je peux
l'utiliser
je suis pas gamer j'ai tout ça bien
évidemment dans cette jolie boîte qui
arrivait chez moi je me suis équipé
comme un bon boucher
alors je pense que là j'attaque pâques
qu'est ce que j'ai ici mega trinity on
va l'ouvrir
on va regarder un peu ce produit on va
voir s'il est cool on va regarder un peu
les différentes possibilités qu'on a
avec ce produit là et puis au final vous
me direz vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire naga trinity alors là je
vais vous le défaire reprenant avec le
couteau du crime directement ici on va
essayer de tout arracher
berlin est avait sommes là j'adore les
packagings chez razer c'est vraiment
très très beau naga trinity gaming mouse
de ce que j'ai compris sur ce produit de
ce qui est génial c'est que vous avez
effectivement toute une partie qui est
interchangeable c'est ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant que ce produit
c'est le côté personnalisation
moi je trouve que la boîte est super
jolie hop on fait un petit tour on le
retrouve aussi compatible bien
évidemment windows 10 et mac
c'est vraiment très très joli très bien
foutu on ouvre up
la langue est ici aller est ce qu'il y a
à l'intérieur c'est très sympa quand
goitschel 0,19 limbach merci riser un
petit mot très sympa effectivement c'est
vraiment très très calé alors bon ce
qu'on va faire c'est que on va regarder
tout ça comme dirait que mort comme ça
vient pas ici mots coquins naga trinity
ce que j'adore vraiment chez razer c'est
l'univers graphique les choix des
couleurs je trouve que ce ver est
vraiment très très très très beau
d'ailleurs j'ai eu la chance de voir
leur stand au cms à las vegas c'était
vraiment super impressionnant
sauf que vraiment ils ont vraiment une
charte graphique une pâte une création
qui est magnifique elle ça pèse son
poids quand même hein alors comme je
vous le dis moi je suis pas un gamer
donc effectivement j'arrive devant une
souris j'appelle vraiment une souris en
tout cas mais c'est vrai que la prise en
main elle est juste incroyable vous avez
un accès aux touches qui est hyper
rapide et on trouve vraiment sa position
de façon hyper intuitive vous avez
vraiment un emplacement qui optimise et
on s'en va pour pas eu tous fatigués la
main quand on joue c'est vraiment super
bien foutue bien pensé ce qui est super
cool sur le côté on voit que la touche 2
par exemple à un relief qui est
différent par rapport aux autres et
elles ont toutes des reliefs différent
et on le sent sous le doigt sont
vraiment 8
on sent bien le 11 par rapport aux 10 et
aux 12 ça veut dire que lorsqu'on joue
on a vraiment une sensation et on voit
vraiment un accès rapide à ses touches
et on n'est jamais la réponse est
toujours sur lequel on est c'est vrai
que d'un point de vue ergonomique je
trouve que le produit super bien fait en
plus la bombasse à 100 en plastique dur
classique là par contre vous avez un
côté qui est traîtresse où c'est un côté
un peu caoutchouteux en apprenant sa
leçon de maîtrise de l'objet dans la
pâte trouve ça vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien conçu c'est ça que j'adore
chez razer
regardez la finition même là vous avez
l'empreinte vert au niveau de l'ue
explique c'est ça qui est vraiment
géniale sur cette marque c'est que le
packaging les produits le marketing
tout est super bien fait c'est hyper
sexy ce qui est génial c'est que leur
logo au final vous le tenez y perd
facilement et c'est effectivement une
marque est hyper hyper fort dans le
monde du gaming je trouve vraiment super
boulot
même le cap qui est utilisé ici il est
hyper qualitatif ici vous avez un truc
un petit peu un petit peu la ch'ti alors
fait voir comment ça marche tout ça
lorsque je veux changer
génial ah mais c'est aimanté non
sérieusement ouf les cimes donc là j'ai
un petit aimant j'en ai un autre de
l'autre côté
j'aimais connecteurs ici ce qui fait que
ça vient trouver sa position tout seul
ah ouais on est regardé ce truc c'est
ouf quoi c'est complètement dingue
ah ouais non mais c'est génial aller
mais qu'il ya des mecs qui sont creusés
le symbole pour trouver la meilleure
solution
enfin si ouvre donc ça c'est la deuxième
confie que vous avez les deux boutons
sur le côté
alors effectivement là vous avez
l'écouté toujours un petit peu patins
antidérapants ce fait vous avez une
vraie maîtrise
il faut vraiment la sensation avec deux
doigts de la tenir ça peut pas glisser
c'est ouf complètement ouf la sensation
de maîtrise away ou fissible génial tu
es la troisième partie c'est celle là
hop
pareil je prends je d'eclyps il veut
juste cherché à le poser dessus assez
dingue
leur système est complètement dingue
c'est vraiment génial
je pensais vraiment que j'allais avoir
un espace de trucs à des clips s'est
appuyée à sortir un bien bon il pourrait
y avoir un petite encoche un truc un peu
embêtant à dire on va le casser et au
risque d'endommager le produit même pas
mon lapin tu prends tu parles hop hop
attention voilà cette souris pour m
amuser rien qu'à faire ça ça c'est oit
c'est fabuleux
alors la sensation j'ai vraiment le pavé
sous le doigt sous le pouce c'est
vraiment génial parce que c'est hyper
intuitif regardez là je la tiens ils
m'ont pouces il est vraiment sur le jeu
au milieu ce qui fait que dès lors je
connais un peu mais touche c'est tout ce
que je suis en plus là il ya un côté
antidérapant au milieu j'ai vraiment la
sensation de contrôle et de maîtrise je
me mets là je glisse pas j'suis pas
comme sur le bout de plastique ou l'âge
pour un bien on doit la glisse et ça
m'est pénible
non là je suis là ça ne bouge pas là du
bout du doigt je sens bien la fente là
entre le 1 et le 2 à west ham 2 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 d'accord donc pas un deux trois
c'est très très facilement sous le doigt
du coup avec le 4 et 5 sont là et
logiquement 6 et 7 sont là donc 1 2 3 4
5 6 est génial dans l'est franchement je
trouve que d'un point de vue ergonomie
d'un point de vue prise en main le
produit ouf
on va maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va prendre cette jolie peu sourit
et on va la brancher directement dans
mon acte on va regarder ce que ça dit je
vais essayer de le défaire
[Musique]
genia regardez-moi ça l'éclairage est
ouf
vous avez l'éclairage qui changent et
changent de couleur le pavé sur le côté
la molette ou alors vous allez me dire
mais c'est quoi ce mec il est connu
maria
je ne savais pas et je trouve ça super
cool moi je l'essaie vraiment comme une
souris classique
j'imagine que les puristes vont me saute
à la gorge dans les temps mais c'est
quoi ce mec il a une super souris et ils
l'utilisent comme un petit mieux vaut un
peu classique ok je suis d'accord mais
comme je vous le dis je suis pas gamers
mais ce que j'adore à ce que j'apprécie
énormément
c'est vraiment la prise en main de ce
produit je creuse est génial c'est
vraiment très très pratique parce que
vous avez une vraie sensation de
maîtrise ce qui est vraiment génial
c'est contre le pouce et l'annulaire
j'ai vraiment session de prise en main
de maîtrise de la naga trinity génial
alors effectivement là j'en fais pas
grand chose j'ai pas utilité tout ça
parce que je suis pas un gamer mais
j'imagine que quelqu'un qui joue pas
vraiment avoir une utilité complète la
partie effectivement avec les 12 touch
serait plus destiné aux gamers qui joue
sous both worlds warcraft avec les sept
touches on serait davantage sur des jeux
comme heroes store et diablo iii mais je
pense que sur cette configuration un peu
plus classique avec juste les deux
boutons pour on est sur un truc hyper
clasico cela par exemple vous n'avez pas
de rétroéclairage ça fait vraiment
souris classique navistar vraiment en
profiter pour faire plein de choses à
les personnaliser
vous avez soit effectivement la partie
ici à 12 touches soit la partie à cette
touche
moi je trouve en tout cas que ce produit
est super sympa très joli ce que je
trouve bluffant est génial c'est
vraiment la prise en main c'est
l'ergonomie
alors comme je vous le dis une fois de
plus je suis pas un gamer mais j'imagine
que si je les passais des heures et des
heures à jouer je serai content d'avoir
une souris qui va vraiment avoir un
touch r go no milk ça peut paraître
ridicule à dire mais effectivement
quitte à passer des heures avec une
souris à la main
il faut vraiment à quelque chose qui ce
qui est pousse vraiment la forme de
votre main pour vraiment avoir un
confort de jeu et je trouve que là en
tout cas la razer naga trinity lé top
vole un petit peu pour ce review un peu
rapide de la part d'henri meurent pour
un produit de gamer si vous êtes gamer
dites moi si vous l'avez déjà utilisés
réseaux nga trinity est-ce que vous avez
déjà utilisé d'autres produits de razer
est ce que vous pensez que razer est
vraiment au top sur ses accessoires ou
alors à ce que d'autres marques qui sont
très très bien si oui vous marquez tout
ça en commentaire je vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
c'est une saga trinity vous intéresse je
vous aimais bien évidemment un lien dans
la description pour aller à trouver
merci beaucoup
razer chez super content d'avoir pu
l'essayer 2010 si un petit peu aux
produits gaming allez savoir peut-être
qu'un jour je veux dire gamer moi aussi
maintenant je me sens super cool merci
beaucoup merci d'abord regarder la vidéo
si elle vous êtes plus je vous invite à
laisser des jolies pousse à vous abonner
parce qu'on va paraître toujours plus de
produits innovante de produits tech
restez connecté il ya plein de surprises
et plein de choses qui vont arriver je
vous remercie beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d toujours plus nombreux et d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo
parlez-en autour de vous parler à vos
amis merci vous êtes les meilleurs
je vous embrasse et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]